it was 113 degrees where this mother a
columbia mother and her daughter were
found dead in the desert of arizona
after crossing the border to seek asylum
her name was claudia marcela pena and
she shared a photo of her young daughter
carrying her little brother the
two-year-old through the desert and
hours later claudia and her ten-year-old
daughter died from heat exposure
claudia's husband who lives down in
florida saying quote i told her to go
back she said she was already there then
my daughter said no dad i really want to
see you they only had 25 percent battery
left on their phone claudia made a
frantic call to 9-1-1 for help but her
phone died before she could send the
location
national border patrol council president
brandon judd joins us right now brandon
good morning to you it's a tragic story
you know what it's like out there when
it is hot like that
yeah this this story hurts any border
patrol agent that has ever had to deal
with death
we understand that without proper policy
without proper programs in place we just
can't reach these individuals in time
and to know that this tragedy was
preventable to know that we had we had
the proper resources in the in in the
area and available we would have been
able to save these these people and
we've had agents that have died put
their lives on the line going in to save
these people so that's what we want to
do and to know that this was preventable
really upsets us and and it hurts
knowing that we've had to see this over
and over again the president is securing
tajikistan which borders afghanistan to
protect the folks there from the taliban
and our southern border agents say that
this is a slap in the face he'll secure
that border but not ours they say it's
heartening to see that biden
administration finally getting serious
about border security it's just too bad
it's in another country they say this is
a slap in the face to the u.s and
biden's already destroyed afghanistan so
the borders don't need to be open what's
your reaction brandon
yeah we have complete and total chaos on
our southwest border we don't know who's
coming in we don't know where they're
coming from we don't know what their
intentions are here in the united states
yet he's willing to go and secure a
border of another country his
responsibility is to his citizens to to
all the people that are crossing the
border illegally to everybody that's
currently here that's where his
responsibility is yet he's failing in
that and he's failing miserably when we
look at the threats that we face on a
daily basis and the protection of the
citizens of this country where is he in
and he's nowhere to be found and yes it
is very ironic that he's willing to go
and secure the border of another country
but he's not willing to secure our own
borders for our own citizens it is
frustrating for so many people brandon
thank you very much for joining us today
always good to be with you thank you
thank you